what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime I'm Lauren today I will be
breaking down the latest craziness in
the black clover story including the
fate of some major characters whose
lives appear to be in mortal danger the
outbreak of an all-out war between the
demonic dark triad and the heart clover
Alliance and the upcoming showdown
between the one and only Yami suka hero
and the leader of the dark triad Dante
so much is happening in the story right
now the epic war is only getting started
so let's get into it
if you enjoyed the black clover content
here on the channel and you want us to
keep it going please leave a like to let
me know and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications I want to quickly
apologize for the fact that this video
is dropping later than usual but sadly
I've been sick with a cold all week so
recording the audio was almost
impossible until now big thank you to my
visual editor Takota broski for being so
flexible and helping me get this video
out to you guys definitely showed the
coda some love he has his own channel he
makes quality web content link in the
description
finally this video will of course
contain black horror manga spoilers were
dealing with the latest craziness in the
story so please proceed with caution you
have been warned chapter 239 is called
the budding of Yggdrasil which is a
direct reference to a mythical tree from
Norse mythology we pick up right where
the previous chapter left off with you
know seemingly dead his eyes open and
blankly staring into nothing and self
the wind spirit crying over you knows
motionless body and asking him not to
leave her Ralph is also distraught and
he calls out to you know but his words
are interrupted by a strange commotion
that shakes the rubble beneath his feet
suddenly tree branches surge from
beneath the rubble and they seem to
engulf everything and everyone around
them it turns out that this is a healing
spell created by Captain William in his
world tree recovery magic the budding of
Yggdrasil
thanks to this incredible spell you know
suddenly
as do Klaus L'Etoile and multiple other
members of the Golden Dawn squad the
spell was able to heal those who were on
the brink of death but it could not
bring back to life those members of the
squad who were already dead
this means that shiden hamon and many
others roughly half of the entire Golden
Dawn squad are dead and are presumably
going to stay dead coincidentally the
ones who died are all minor characters
whom we didn't get to attach to
although at this point we are not quite
sure what shape William himself is in we
know that he was badly injured by xenon
and we know that he just used a lot of
his magic and life energy in order to
create this incredible recovery spell so
does this mean that William is OK and
his world tree magic is just that
impressive
or does it mean that he just gave the
last of his life force for this spell
and he might actually die afterwards
this chapter doesn't answer the question
of what state William is currently in
but what we do know is that half of the
Golden Dawn squad members are dead and
you know is upset and furious you know
believes that if only he had been
stronger he could have prevented the
death of his comrades but because he
couldn't stop Zenon he wasn't able to
save half of his squad from getting
killed the days of you know always being
calm and cool are definitely over this
experience has changed you know and he
is now far more emotional and agitated
than he has ever been before and
speaking of you know the previous
chapter chapter two three eight had
strongly implied that you know along
with Klaus and L'Etoile might all be
dead as I mentioned in my previous black
clover video I did not think that this
would really happen I said that maybe
Klaus and L'Etoile being less important
characters might be dead but you know
would not die because he is too
important to the story and we know that
yuki Tabata does not like killing
important characters i mean just look at
what happened with julius it turns out
that along with you know Klaus and
L'Etoile are also safe which is good
because I didn't want to lose my waifu
with glasses and no I don't mean Klaus I
mean the other one but even though we
didn't lose the major characters only
the minor ones we still can't under
state the importance of the fact that
half of the Golden Dawn members really
did die and we're still not too sure
about what happened to William so while
those of us who were worried about you
know and L'Etoile and I guess Klaus can
let out a sigh of relief these events
that just took place are going to have a
profound influence on the story don't
forget that you know is the vice-captain
of the Golden Dawn and that he feels
directly responsible for the safety of
his comrades it turns out that he was
not strong enough to protect them he
failed to defeat xenon and as a result
many of his comrades perished no matter
what happens now you know will never be
the same again we can already see that
he has changed he is more emotional and
agitated than he has ever been and I am
certain that from this point onward you
know will be driven by a desire to
avenge his comrades and destroy xenon
and the dark triad this means that you
know we'll be more motivated than ever
to keep getting stronger but it also
means that you no could let emotion get
the better of him in crucial moments so
he could end up making bad decisions
because he is so bent on getting revenge
instead of thinking strategically and
retreating when he realizes that he has
no chance of winning you know might let
anger get the best of him and this could
put his life in danger in the coming
chapters and speaking of danger the end
of this chapter has made it clear that
the world of black clover is now in an
all-out war between the demons of spade
and the clover and Hart kingdoms as the
chapter ends we see vantika of the dark
triad and some of her men heading out to
the Hart Kingdom in order to face off
against Laura Pacheco Veronica even says
that she hopes that beaver girl and her
allies are all in fantastic shape
because that would make wiping them out
even more fun at the same time the third
member of the dark triad Dante makes
some philosophical statements about
humans being evil incarnate and evil
being the true nature of humanity before
taking off to challenge none other than
arcane stage mage Yami suka hero as we
already know the fact that Yami is
considered on arcane stage mage reflects
the unusual characteristics of his dark
magic and I'll talk about that in a
little bit
now the fact that Laura Pacheco is being
targeted by vanakkam makes sense Bieber
girl is the queen of the heart Kingdom
and she has been cursed by the demon
Meggie Cola in the past so the dark
triad would know who she is and as the
ruler of a rival Kingdom that they are
trying to conquer it is not surprising
that she is being targeted directly
however the fact that Dante the presumed
leader of the dark triad is targeting
Yami
is quite interesting Yami is not the
king of any Kingdom and as far as we
know he hasn't faced Miggy Kula or the
other Spade Kingdom demons before so why
is Yami in particular being targeted one
possibility is just his overall power
Yami is definitely one of the strongest
magic Knight captains and since William
and the Golden Dawn were also targeted
it is safe to assume that the dark triad
wants to take out the strongest mages
from the closer and hard kingdoms first
however there is one other thing about
Yami that makes him very interesting for
the dark triad Yami just happens to be
the only known user of dark magic and
dark magic in particular has some rare
and unique properties that might be of
special interest to Dante and the dark
triad dark magic is able to absorb other
spells and dark magic is also capable of
cutting through spatial magic which was
thought to be impossible but most
importantly dark magic is the only known
magic type that isn't directly connected
to demonic power but still has an effect
on otherworldly demonic beings such as
the kotodama demon during the fight
against the kotodama demon we saw that
hasta Santa magic had an effect on the
demon because it comes from another
demon but most magic types from this
world did not have an effect on the
kotodama demon however for some reason
Yami's dark magic did have an effect and
Yami actually played a critically
important role in ultimately defeating
the kotodama demon this might be the
reason why Dante is so interested in
Yami since we know that the dark triad
relies on demonic power
Yami's dark magic could pose a major
threat to their power as we know demons
are not immune to dark magic and if used
properly dark magic could deal
significant damage to even the strongest
of the demons
it is possible that Dante wants to
take Yami down before Yami has the
chance to use his dark magic to its
fullest potential the true nature of
dark magic is still a pretty big mystery
in black clover we know that it is
extremely rare and we know that it has
some very unique properties but we still
don't know why exactly dark magic is so
rare and so unique there could be some
hidden connection between Yami and his
dark magic and the demons and their
power a connection that gives Yami a
powerful advantage over the demons we
will have to wait and see what happens
but it is clear to me that Total War is
finally here you know has changed as a
character and he will never be the same
the dark triad is on the move and
preparing to deal a massive blow to the
clover heart alliance and we are about
to be blessed with a truly epic showdown
between the leader of the dark triad
Dante and the one and only Yami suka
hero who is not only one of the
strongest characters but also one of my
favorite characters in the entire series
the hype is real please let me know what
you guys think about these latest
developments are you relieved that you
know is still alive I know that some of
you might be disappointed because you
thought that he really died but
personally I never thought that Tabata
would kill him off I think we can all
agree that L'Etoile surviving is also a
very good thing and I guess Klaus is
pretty cool are you excited to see Dante
and vantika in action for the first time
and how awesome is the fight between
Dante and Yami going to be please share
your thoughts down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video you want to
see more black clover content on the
channel please leave a like to let me
know and if you happen to be new to
anime or don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest black clover news and
updates I want to give a big thank you
to all of our anime opera patrons who
support our content and make these
videos possible first up let me thank
our the one tier patrons the ones who
rise above all other clans including
ingrid ah alone
makoto-kun the world Steelers the school
bus and Tyson query know I also can't
forget our awesome pro hero to your
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings L dress very dolla beat alpha do
Anatoli Cassatt ski on hell Cruz team
Sparky 65 cricket XP Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney Emperor otaku Timothy E
vodkas Jean d'Arc and Jose Staunton if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our page
and exclusive discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see us bass cowboys
[Music]